Here's a quick story, just about another one
of these self-inflicted embarrassments for
the current administration.
Yesterday, you actually had two press events,
but both of which I covered live in the morning.
You had Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley
McKenny, do a standard press briefing where
she comes out, speaks for like 90 seconds.
75 seconds are usually her lies.
The other 15 are just saying hello.
And then in the afternoon, Donald Trump did
his own press briefing.
And what was very interesting was that in
the morning, the topic of testing came up
and the topic of Trump not wearing a mask
came up.
And weirdly, when Kaley McCannon, he was trying
to defend Trump, not wearing a mask in many
situations.
She said, listen, Trump's tested multiple
times a day for Corona virus, which is weird.
And I'll play that part of this for you first.
And don't tell me he hasn't won.
So it's sending mixed signals.
The president wore a mask in May.
The president wore a mask at Walter Reed out
of an abundance of caution.
But as I've made clear from this podium, the
president is the most tested man in America.
He's tested more than anyone multiple times
a day.
And we believe that he's acting appropriately.
The president is tested for corona virus multiple
times per day.
That's definitely odd, but OK.
So then hours later, you knew it was going
to happen.
Donald Trump was asked earlier, your press
secretary said you're tested multiple times
per day for Corona virus.
Can you talk about how frequently that's happening?
And Trump says he looks clearly confused and
he says, I can't even think of one time where
I was tested more than once in a day.
Usually I'm tested once every two or three
days.
What was.
Yeah, take a look to president.
First, though, Chorney clarification.
Your press secretary said today that you sometimes
take more than one test today.
Why is that?
How?
Well, I didn't know about more than one.
I do test probably on average a test every
two days, three days.
And I don't know of any time I've taken two
tests in one day, but I could see that happening.
So this is once again not an issue of interpretation.
This is just a very concrete, practical matter.
Kaley McKenny defends Trump's lack of mask
wearing by saying he's getting tested multiple
times per day.
Now, if that were true, that would raise questions
of why are most people waiting five to seven
days for results?
And Trump's getting multiple tests with almost
immediate results.
Although I get it, he's the president.
But the point is, we still have a testing
problem in this country.
If you don't get your results back for five
to seven days, as many people don't.
You can spread the disease to multiple people
while you're waiting for your test results.
And Trump is barely wearing a mask and getting
multiple tests per day.
But then Trump just straight up says, I don't
know anything about multiple tests in a day.
I'm tested once every two to three days.
So if there is a briefing today, I'm sure
Kaylie McEnany will be asked about it.
I'm sure she'll have some prepared explanation
that may already have happened by the time
you see this, or maybe there will be no press
briefing at all today.
But as usual, caught lying again.
And the theme is they go too far when there's
bye.
I don't want to say this is this is a normal
question.
Everybody's told to wear masks.
Why isn't Trump wearing one when they see
a hostile question and accusatory question?
As far as they're concerned, they go overboard
in trying to defend.
And that's how you get this.
Why isn't Trump wearing a mask?
Oh, he's tested all the time.
He's tested multiple times a day.
And there's other examples of this.
When Trump says something racially off color
and then he's called on it.
He'll say things like, I am the least racist
person ever.
That got a hold on a sec.
That's a weird thing to say.
Maybe just say you're not racist, but the
least racist person ever, you know, saying
I'm not racist.
That wouldn't be any more believable, quite
frankly.
But it would at least be more plausible.
Or when asked about testing, Trump says we
have the best and the most testing.
Well, no way.
The best.
Not really the most.
No.
Not per capita.
The fastest results.
Certainly not.
When asked about deaths, Trump says we have
the lowest mortality rate.
Well, no, we don't.
Of course, none of these things are true.
And it is another one of these little self-inflicted
cuts that comes from trying to be hyperbolic
and go against anything perceived.
I mean, there's so trigonal, there's so thin
skinned that would qualify as just a basic,
obvious journalistic question in any other
country with a free press here, these are
seen as attacks.
And they actually generate obvious and provable
lies.